welcome back to las vegas now envy
energy the sponsors of today's segment
work hard to make their self-service
options easy and quick for their
customers and here to tell us more is
envy energy vice president of customer
operations antoine tillman thank you for
being here thank you so a lot to talk
about you guys do so much for our
community with envy energy but let's
talk about these self-service options
what does that mean and how do you guys
make it easy for your customers so
basically anything that when you call us
you can actually also do that online so
you can go to your my account establish
an account and then you can actually do
a start
stop service you can transfer your
service you can
check your account you can go paperless
you can
set up alerts and that's really
important if you make a payment with us
and instead of calling us and saying hey
did you receive our payments we'll
actually send you alert and all of that
information is online so we all know
sometimes it can be frustrating when you
have to call customer service number and
you're talking to robots and you're
pushing a button you're yelling into the
phone so was that kind of the idea to
just make it user friendly for every one
of your customers at mv energy yes what
we did was we actually looked at the
calls that were coming in and then there
are calls that are going through our ivr
system and we said what's an easier way
for us a person to do a transaction so
we moved all of that information
and those functions to our website and
some of us are impatient and we want our
answers right now you know five minutes
ago but do you guys offer kind of a live
chat or some way to easily communicate
through the website yes we do have chat
we have email
our chat function is right there it's
accessible you can actually do some of
those same things um through there and
if you if you need that assistance you
can click there and say agent and it'll
bring you right to one of our agents and
let's talk about some of the alerts that
people can sign up for can you pick and
choose what's important to you and where
do those alerts come from and how do you
receive them yes so there we we have a
list of about four or five of them the
most important ones are payments and
then um your when your bill is due as as
well as outages outages is very
important so those ones we opt you in
and you can opt out of those okay and
those are just many of the the alerts
that we have but they're all very very
important and unique to the person and
is that something you recommend your
customers doing getting those alerts i
don't think we realize how important
they are until you're not getting
correct correct please
we highly recommend that you get the
alerts it gives you the information that
you need for your account and it makes
your life easier because you don't have
to call us absolutely well antoine thank
you so much for breaking all this down
this is really important for everyone to
know how easy it is because sometimes it
can be intimidating if you you know have
to pick up a phone or go online but you
make it very user friendly for everyone
thank you thank you for breaking it down
and all of your information on your
screen if you want to learn more just
visit nvenergy.com
self service we'll be right back